so the first season of agents of
Shield's wrapped up and aside from a
little blurb about a week or so back I
haven't really talked about this show
cuz I haven't really cared but you know
what I finished the entire first season
so you know what let's throw out some
thoughts on the thing I should probably
mention up front this is going to be
riddled with spoilers so if you are not
caught up on the entire first season and
it matters to you you might want to
leave about now in the interest of this
not just me a complete bashing of the
thing book let's start with what works
some of the cast works really well Clark
Gregg returning as Agent Coulson he was
good he was always good i wish he had
been the central focus a little more
firmly he actually felt sidelined a lot
of the time so even though he was really
good i feel like he got underused me now
when playing May she's just awesome I
mean I just love her she is inherently
awesome and she was just perfectly stoic
kick ass you didn't want to mess with
this chick which is it's hard to do that
sort of character without them just
seeing boring or phony but she just
owned that and was terrific the really
strong guest stars showed up as well
Patton Oswalt oh he was awesome please
please tell me he's gonna be a regular
in season 2 it would elevate the show
immediately Bill Paxton worked really
well for what they used him forth and
the character by design wasn't a huge
fan of but he played it really well and
some of the other things that work I
really have to talk about what didn't
work first because they were the ways
that the show improved so um well you
may have noticed I only mentioned two
members of the regular cast cuz the rest
of them it was the character of sky who
was fine there was nothing wrong with
her me the woman who played or did
pretty well she was you know energetic
and fun but the character just that
didn't particularly interest me Fitz and
Simmons now these two just by Concepcion
annoyed and it's kind of become a bit of
a new television cliche I've got a
friend of it calls it the power nerd in
my mind that they're really then they're
technobabble wizards they're there to
fix whatever seemingly unsolvable
problem by
doing some technical jargon and suddenly
oh now we can open this door or stop
this machine or do whatever whatever it
was impossible to do before and if we
now suddenly do through the magic of
science and they were just boring in
their chemistry and the unrequited love
it was so predictable I did one of the
ballsiest things this show did was get
them in a position where they were gonna
die but it didn't have a good
follow-through to actually kill them I
really wish it had another character I
want to die and I mentioned this last
time I talked about the show ward he
should have died he should be dead and
that's not really being driven by the
fact that I don't like the character I
don't for the record let's be clear but
the reason I sending these diets because
leaving him alive him coming back is
gonna serve no proper function he should
not be redeemed he really should not he
took action to kill these other two and
as far as he knew he they were dead so
it wasn't like oh I secretly saved you
like no he tried to kill them his
betrayal of the team was so fundamental
and so long-lived that there is no
reason for him to come back he does not
reserve to debt redemption he should
have just died and the last episode of
the show kind of made it clear that they
weren't going to go all out vism villain
with him they were gonna leave that
little bit of all but he still got note
kill him I wanted him to die actually I
wanted to die in a very specific way I
wanted sky to kill him I wanted her to
put two bullets in his head take him out
no more issues with him as far as story
issues go cuz it's gonna cause a mess
when they inevitably bring him back and
bonus it would have been like full
indoctrination of sky into this world of
spies and life and death situations and
I think that would have solved a whole
lot of problems the entire first half of
the season I barely even remember I mean
format wise it was kind of a unusual
occurrence of the week thing and you
know that sort of form i really had its
heyday with X Files and Buffy very few
shows have been able to pull it off
since then fringe kinda did it but it's
just a format that doesn't seem to work
anymore and this show is stuck in that
format for the first half but
wasn't just that there was just
something about the fact that even
though this was a small team that it was
had the entire force of shield behind it
so when they go and take out one dude
who can kind of do fire or some guy who
built the weather Dominator from GI Joe
out of the garage parts you know it's
like if they almost feel like bullies it
feels like they're not taking anybody
that's actually a threat to them I mean
I understand the people they're taking
out or dangerous and whatever but it
almost seemed like you know what local
authorities maybe could have taken care
of that for you it didn't require this
which was another part of the problem
this this show had a real big villain
issue because there for most of the show
that was never revealing big enough and
then one of one finally emerged they
dropped the ball on that to the show got
better overall when two things happen I
first perked up when Deathlok just the
word showed up now obviously that
introduced the character would become
Deathlok way early in the season but I
didn't know where that was going but as
soon as they drop that name it became
clear that he was going to be that
character i perked up partly because the
show has really underdone the
integration of marvel war into it into
its storylines now i understand that
they don't want to just take stories
directly from the comic books and do
those because then people watching
who've read the comics already know
what's going to happen so i get the
aversion to that but you just drop some
characters especially you forget
storylines just give us characters some
names that we know just throw us a bone
Deathlok was a fairly big bone it took
forever for us to get it Deathlok i feel
this kind of kid was okay he paid off
really well at the end I'll give him
that but when that word first showed up
on screen that's my first perked up but
the show noticeably got better when the
second captain america movie happened
and the cross over there and the fallout
of basically hydra having infiltrated
shield and pretty much taken the damn
thing over suddenly we had a villain we
had a villain worthy of shield and
what's more the team didn't have the
full force of shield behind them anymore
now they were on there
oh and then they were really the
underdogs and suddenly I was much more
interested and much more invested in
what that we're doing unfortunately the
show kind of dropped the ball on this
all the same because they gave us Hydra
they gave us this bigger villain but
then they just narrowed it right down
and had this focus only on Garrett and
we lost sight of the size and the scope
of Hydra and what Hydra was doing just
so we could focus on this one dude and
if you were to go by the show although
you might kind of go is Hydra no longer
an issue now that he's out of the
picture I I don't know I mean I know
Hydra still an issue because you saw
Baron Strucker in the post credits on on
Winter Soldier and he hasn't been dealt
what's so obviously hydras still out
there somewhere buddy they just narrowed
it down to this one dude and then they
got rid of him now his death would
freaking awesome both of them they were
terrific the second one especially
though but these moments like that that
the show needs more of because a lot of
it just feels really generic and I guess
this is my main thing at the end of the
day this doesn't really feel like part
of the Marvel Universe it feels like it
could be said anywhere and feature any
characters it under utilizes the things
that tie it to the marvel cinematic
universe or to the comic books now what
me back to the second season yeah
probably enough things turned around in
the second half and especially in the
last episode that last episode was good
it was solid and enough things happen in
that that made me go okay okay things
like with sky and with Coulson and what
the sort of things that were left off
not really cliffhangers but like threads
planted to be picked up in the next
season I'm not going to say I'm invested
but I'm intrigued I'm intrigued enough
to come back and give the second season
a shot because we've got a second season
and also we're going to be getting the
limited season of agent Carter which I
really hope they can at least integrate
that into ages of shield better than
they have the actual Marvel Cinematic
Universe because one of the coolest
things that was going on is when they is
in those last couple episodes where
they're they're having to use
old-fashioned tech from the days of the
Howling Commandos which first of all the
guy whose grandfather was in the Helen
came out his trip they need to make him
a permanent part of the team because he
beats the hell out of Ward he's fun he's
energetic Ward was stupid and boring and
annoying that
ridiculous romantic anger I don't care
didn't care before he was a traitor once
he was a traitor was like cool we can
kill him and they didn't even do that
anyway bring it back I like that sort of
integration a curse on shows that early
sense of you know here's all the sudden
one before and I can impact how things
are going on now and I'm hoping we can
get that feel between a second season of
agents of shield and of agent Carter so
I SAT through it I watched it I I feel
like I I feel like we were promised and
it had the potential to be so much more
than it was I mean that and that's
ultimately why I'm just gonna but it and
then again it's also i'm gonna come back
because i think it can be more than it
has been up at this point there's a
chance that maybe it will be cross my
fingers on come back next season I gotta
lever do an episode that by episode
breakdown on this show I just I'm not
invested enough in it the way I am with
something like Game of Thrones or what
I'll start doing with Doctor Who ones
that comes back I'm sure but if there is
a major seminal episode maybe I'll come
back and then you know do my thoughts on
that but for right now I I'm ready to
take a break from this show anybody else
been following this thing do you plan to
come back for next season are you
excited for next season where have you
landed on this thing overall am I being
too hard on it drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it and
until next time this council is
adjourned